Earl Thomas on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Earl what is it like playing in
a game like that obviously you've had
many many many games up in the Pacific
Northwest where the weather is kind of
frightful cold and chilly and rainy but
what what in the world is it like to
play in a game like that in those
conditions
yeah so yeah so the weather the weather
was definitely affecting the game it was
wet and it was slippery so it was the
footing was the issue but you just had
to play through it but the conditions
really affected the game well I mean
when it comes down to it you do you put
it out of your mind I mean do you notice
it while you're going through your
business do the conditions where you
know that they have the the seat warmers
on the sideline and then they have the
heaters so I just tried to stay warm and
then once you leave that area is your
back cold so you just tried to manage it
the best way as possible but like I said
the field was very slippery and I was
watching sailing now and a couple of
guys I would say you just see them just
take maybe three back Turtles and they
slipped so it was still got the job and
that's all that matters yeah where do
the Niners rank in terms of teams you
played this year well I think I think
the tip of the game allows you know the
OCE to keep Jimmy G and again this other
game turns out now now if it was if we
grow by 10 and Lamar doesn't get strip
right there maybe the situation changed
but I still don't get this tune probably
one of the best seasons played the
seasons I think they came on defense and
all things ready to play balls in our
house so it was definitely tough matchup
well can you compare him with the
Patriots well I can't compare because it
was two different games and it was like
it was two different outcomes they
definitely played us I guess better then
the pagers play this just based on how
the game turns out sorry I guess I don't
want to give them the airs on the
Patriots because you know it's just any
you can't count the Pacers down and I
don't want to put the 49ers over the
patrons but
celery yeah I know I certainly I don't
know if you you saw how the Patriots
struggled offensively against the Texans
last night but you've seen them all
and you've begun to just start pounding
people and the question I have for you
is uh D you sometimes watch your offense
because you're you've got Lamar Jackson
out there clearly you've got business to
do once you're you're off the field but
I'm wondering if you're watching what's
going on on the field because of Lamar
yeah I'm watching because I'm rooting
for these guys like if they were a
success he's definitely not gonna have
no success so we watching everything but
we definitely turn it to fans on Lamar
does it does little more things like
when you break it people ankles out
there spinning wonderful you know crazy
yards making a crazy throw downfield
that only the more to do and we just
talked about on the sideline and I just
think it kind of makes us comfortable on
the sideline as well going in for the
next series
Errol Thomas here on the Rich Eisen show
do you need a 9-volt battery for
something in your house right now Earl
no I'm good
sounds like your fire your smoke alarm
is going off in the background there so
okay very good now we got to get you got
to make sure everything's safe certainly
since you're going to the Super Bowl
this year based on what you said earlier
in all so yeah the question you were
asked if the Niners if this is a Super
Bowl preview you wrote you think the
Niners to go to the Super Bowl it could
be let's see when the Super Bowl comes
whoever we play they're going to be in
trouble did you realize what was coming
out of your mouth when you were saying
that well I just I'm very confident in
the squad and I don't think first of all
that would make a big deal out of it I
was just talking to the local media but
I really believe that we really have a
legitimate shot to go to a Super Ball
and they asked the question so they
basically forced it out of me I didn't
have anywhere to run so I basically said
what was over mine I really believe that
we have a chance to be in a Super Bowl
and just like every other Sunday that we
play on Thursday on the grass it's gonna
be a hard battle when you
it's go time what similarities are there
between the two guys who appear to be in
the one-two in the battle for MVP and
he'll make his latest case tonight on
Monday Night Football against the
Vikings Lamar and Russell who he's
played with yeah they're very versatile
players and then you know you can't
really scheme for backyard football so
they both bring that to the table and in
this hole for defense is especially when
they running and they trying that D line
out and you know four quarters that's
what else has so what happens if let's
play this out since you did or the media
as you point out open the door what if
we could go to Miami you're there for
the Super Bowl and it's Seattle across
the way what would that mean it would
mean that I would have some film that
already you know stimulated and play the
game against this thing I'm not gonna
make it a girls coming home or ought to
do that so I got that out of my system
that was it was just be Seattle and she
I will prepare my butt off the team will
prepare myself and she will go out there
and do it to do what's it been like to
be coached by John Harbaugh how have you
because again easier he's the first non
Pete Carroll coach that you've had in
the NFL what's it been like walk me
through that process here it's been a
smooth process this communication with
me has been great
and that's all I can ask for and other
than that you know just take a day by
day if some come up and talk if not a
and I'm going on about my business and
does this feel like a Super Bowl team
again you've been on one you've been in
a couple of them I mean does it do you
have that feeling it's a similar for you
yeah so rich I just I just went on a
limb and told the media which is that's
about so the media yeah I feel like you
know we gotta make it to Super Bowl so I
definitely feel like this is a Super
Bowl team like we have that in fact on
both sides of the ball
all phases okay so do I take that as
another guarantee that you're backing it
up again I'm just having fun with the
Earl so okay so now next up for you guys
Buffalo I don't know were you able to
catch the the bills and cowboys on
Thanksgiving sleeping so how I wake up a
little bit but I didn't really catch the
game I just catch more serum okay so
watch a couple of games oh well you said
it's difficult to to defend mobile or
scheme for mobile quarterbacks Josh
Allen is certainly that Earl I mean how
do you try obviously you've be able to
practice against the MVP who is very
mobile but how do you prepare for that
well we're going to talk about in the
game plan here pretty quickly would you
like to work tomorrow so that's what
that's it and for me and for the players
just get back to fundamentals day one
get your fundamentals down get
everything your angles right your
Corrections from the game last game it
was just play and then you move forward
so the coaches you know start talking
about it the players will start
discussing in more and more info we get
so right now I'm really have already
started to be told
okay very good and what's your favorite
Lamar play that you've seen this year
the one that made me cause you to stop
in your tracks
yeah so the one who gets this anadi the
the he brung a lot B was a QB design run
and you should like two or three people
sparked and then scored and then I got
another one too so the one he just did
this this game 24 trying to come track
homeboy yeah he went in and anyway it
came back man and a field was already
slippery sort of looked bad he sat him
down is what he did yeah is that ever
happening is that about me you on the
field
yeah well who did you remember who did
it to you I mean happened to me last
game 30 31 I remember guys man
he came and he and I were trying to get
up a block and you know I dropped to my
knees he shouldn't it happens okay so
when I spoke to Bobby Wagner after the
Seahawks beat the 49ers he said he had a
wager with Richard Sherman Lakers
tickets on the game did you have
anything with Sherman on this one I
didn't have anything with Sam so he
takes me up to the game because his wife
and I had basically stayed now sweet for
the game okay
and he was like well he was like [ __ ] I
said I'll pay you any money I was like
no Brock I'd rather just you sit on that
air than we do it was hard okay
so are you saying that your your seat
yours and Richard Sherman's significant
others were watching the game together
in the suite yeah I got a suite yeah
okay but was she showing up in her 49er
gear and everything cool I mean in the
suite okay that's good that's good and
so you told Richard don't worry I got
you on the tickets
you just sit on the El that you just sat
on how did he respond to that can you is
there is it safe for work his response
oh no no you got the call me Kevin
suppose it okay Earl
listen congrats on the W let's chat on
down the line as you guys get closer to
the goal that you you want how about
that let's just put it down right for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app